翻訳: Kaoru Suzuki
校正: Hiroko Kawano
こんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
今 立派な博物館と言っていただきました
福島県立博物館で学芸員をしている
小林といいます
今日はお時間と機会を下さって
ありがとうございます
私は 今日 皆さんに
博物館で携わっている仕事を通して
大事だなとこの数年間感じていることを
お伝えしたくて
お話をさせていただくことにいたしました
福島県立博物館 博物館です
博物館の仕事は
その地域の歴史を 調べて 集めて
そして残して伝えることです
ですから 私が勤めている福島県立博物館は
福島県の歴史を調べて 集めて
残して 伝えることを役割としています
私の仕事は そこに携わって
その博物館の役割を実現していくことです
ですが 最近 その博物館の役割のうち
残し 伝えることというの大切さを
痛感するようになってきました
この数年間 特にそうなんですけれども
その中で博物館として どう残し伝えるか
ということを行っていったらいいか
ということで始めた事業のひとつが
2010年から2012年まで３年間に渡って
福島県立博物館が行ってきた
「会津・漆の芸術祭」という事業です
この事業は 福島県の会津地方に
たくさんあります文化的な資源のうち
漆ということをテーマにおいて行いました
漆は会津では2400年前の
縄文時代からの歴史を持っています
その歴史を持つテーマを選ぶことで
博物館という時間的に遡って
様々なストックを持っている所が
その事業のバックボーンの役割を
果たせると思ったからです
そして 芸術祭という
アートを取り入れることで
表現する人たちの視点を貸していただくこと
この力で私たちは 会津の魅力を漆を通して
発見したり 出会ったり
できるのではないかと考えました
100人ぐらいの作家さん 職人さんたちが
３年間 毎年「会津・漆の芸術祭」に
参加して下さいました
その皆さんの作品一つ一つが
どれも強いメッセージを持っています
ここでは その一つ一つを
ご紹介はできないのですが
その一つを今回ご紹介いたします
まず2010年の一つです
今 ご覧いただいているのは
宮原克人さんという漆の作家さんが
作られた作品です
この芸術祭の時は
皆さんに 博物館企画の
ツアーに参加していただいて
作品を作っていただきました
その土地の歴史 それから漆の技を学んだ上で
作品として伝えていただきたかったからです
宮原さんは 会津若松と喜多方の会場を
ツアーを巡った結果として
喜多方市にある酒蔵の
大和川酒蔵さんを展示会場に選びました
そして 今皆さんがご覧下さっているように
酒瓶が並んでいる場所で
この酒蔵で かつてお酒造りの
仕込み桶として使われていた桶の蓋を
漆で型取って作品にしたんです
この土地のこの場所の歴史
それはひいては この喜多方の地が
とても豊かでおいしい水に恵まれて
おいしい酒造りを何百年にも渡って
してきたということの証でもあります
それを宮原さんは漆という
永続性のとても高い素材を使って
これから将来にも残る
メッセージとして残してくれたのです
こうして この土地土地にある歴史を
作家の視点で豊かに伝えていこうという
私たちの試みは 2011年以降も
続いていくつもりで準備をしていたのですが
ここで 大きく変化をせざるを
得なくなります
2011年の3月11日に
東日本大震災が起き
その後に 東京電力福島第一原子力発電所が
爆発したからです
そこで 私たちは2011年に行う
漆の芸術祭のテーマを
「東北へのエール」と変更しました
多くの表現者の人たちが
皆さんそれぞれの表現手段で
東北へのメッセージ
そして東北から世界に発信すべきメッセージを
作品を通して表現してくれました
現代美術の作家さんたちや
他の漆や様々な表現手段の作家さんたちに
肩を並べて頑張って下さったのは
会津の漆の作り手たちです
今 見ていただいているのは
相田啓介さんという漆の作り手の方が
ご自分が作られた漆器を
展示して下さった物です
相田さんはご自身の器たちに
『再生の時代へ』というタイトルを付けました
ここには 相田さんの
メッセージが込められています
2011年に起きたことから
私たちは多くのことを学ぶことができました
消費し 使って エネルギーをたくさん作り
そして また消費するという社会ではなくて
何かを繰り返し
大切に守りつつ使っていくような
そういう社会の在り方も
必要なのではないかと
相田さんのこの器はメッセージとして
伝えてくれています
会津の多くの漆の作り手は そのようなことを
メッセージとして伝えてくれたのですが
それは漆の作り手たちが
何十年もかけて育った木を分けてもらい
数十年かけて作った漆の液で
塗り物を作るという
自然から何かを分けてもらって
長い時間のスパンの中で
ものづくりをしている人だったからだと
私は思っています
そして 会津の職人さんたちがこうして
2011年に 私たちのテーマ変更に応えて
多くのメッセージを発信して下さったことを
今でも とても誇りに思っています
そして ３年目となった2012年
私たちは漆の芸術祭のテーマを
「地の記憶 未来へ」というものに変えました
ここではアートの力を
また確認することもできました
今 皆さんがご覧になっている画像は
ここの会場のすぐお隣の場所です
末廣酒造さんが古酒を貯蔵している貯蔵庫にも
作品を展示させていただきました
ここに展示されている白い小さな物体は
ある人とある人の握手の間で生まれた
狭間の作品です
2012年 仮設住宅が福島県内で
たくさん建つことができて
避難していた方々が
そちらに移るようになっていった頃でした
会津にも 旅館やホテルなどに
たくさんの方が避難していました
避難していた皆さんが
仮設住宅に移るにあたって
「何か感謝の気持ちも表したい」
そんな言葉も聞こえてきて
私たちは作家さんに相談をしました
そして ある作家さんが
出してくれたアイデアが
その二人の間の握手の間を
粘土を挟むことで
記録していったらどうだろう
ということだったのです
そして 旅館やホテルの
オーナーさんや従業員さん
そして 避難してきた方たちの
間で生まれた握手の記憶が
作家さんによって 白い釉を掛けられ
焼くことがされて
このように
一つ一つの作品になっていきました
そして この白い一つ一つの
小さな小さな大切な作品たちは
会津の漆の職人さんが作ってくれた
大きな黒い漆塗りの
円形の台の上に展示されたのです
「漆黒」という言葉があります
漆の黒ですよね
漆はとても深い
そして 輝くような黒を出します
とても磨きあげられた黒い面というのは
私たちの姿もほんのり映しだしてくれるような
鏡面のような美しい姿も出すことがあります
ここで展示された
白い一人一人の手の間で生まれた
その記憶の形は
この末廣酒造さんの貯蔵庫の床に置かれて
一人一人の記憶を映し出すとともに
この土地の酒蔵の記憶 そして
酒造りをしてきたこの土地の豊かな自然をも
映し出していたようだなと
私は今でも思ってます
こうしてアートは人と人を繋いだり
お互いのそういう思いやりの気持ちを
私たちに見せてくれたり
ということもありました
会津の地がこうして避難してくる人たちを
たくさん受け入れて
今も福島県の被害の大きかった
浜通りや中通りを支え続けています
私はこういうことは 今後もさらに
必要になってくるのではないかと思っています
なぜなら 会津は
今ご覧いただいている作品のように
豊かな時間軸の上に成り立っている
文化や歴史が今も脈々と息づいています
そこに降り立って
会津の地が福島を支えることが
今後とても必要になって
くるのではないかと思っています
なぜなら 浜通りと呼ばれている
原発が立地し 大きな津波災害を受けた土地や
中通りの地域の人たちは
避難することで
その土地と切り離されて
その土地の時間軸から離されてしまう
という危機にも置かれているからです
福島で避難しているいくつかの町村の中に
飯舘村という場所があります
原発が立地している所から離れているために
すぐに避難をするということではなくて
2011年の6月に全村避難が行われました
本当に 青天の霹靂のように まさかここで
という思いの中で村民の人たちは避難していき
土地と離されたことで 村の人たちの中には
自分たちの文化が途切れてしまうのではないか
という危機感がとても大きいです
それは今も一緒です
私たち福島県立博物館は
「いいたて までいの会」という
飯舘村を支援している団体の皆さんと一緒に
その村の姿を かつての文化を 歴史を
少しでも留めることが
できるようにということで
「いいたてミュージアム」という活動を
2012年 2013年あたりから始めました
このプロジェクトは 村の方たちに
その人の歴史をお聞きしていきます
大事にしていること 村での暮らし
どんな生き方をしてきたのか
そんなお話の中から お話の中で
象徴的な物を分けてもらってきています
例えば今ご覧いただいているのは
なんとスズメバチの焼酎漬けです
こんな物がミュージアムの
資料になるって思われますか
でも これは立派な
いいたてミュージアムの資料の一つです
これはある方のお話を聞いて
頂いた物なのですが
その方は定年後 趣味が高じて
蕎麦打ちからさらに発展して
蕎麦作りをしていました
ご存知の方もいらっしゃいますが
お蕎麦というのは
稲よりも もうちょっと寒い
寒冷な土地を好んで実る作物です
飯館村はお米を育てるのには
ちょっと適していなくて
昔は冷害の時には亡くなる方も
いたぐらいの寒冷な土地なのですが
蕎麦作りにはとても適していました
そこで 定年後に楽しく仲間たちと
蕎麦作りをしていた方は
受粉のために蜜蜂を飼います
そうすると 蜜蜂を狙って
スズメバチがやってきました
それをその男性はヒュッと網で採っては
焼酎にスッと漬けていたんだそうです
こうして生まれた
このスズメバチの焼酎漬けは
その方のこの数年間の仲間たちとの
ある意味での食文化のような暮らしを
伝えてくれる物でもあります
飯舘村の自然を伝えてくれる物でもあります
こういう何気ない物 一つ一つから 私たちは
今 途切れてしまうかもしれない
飯館村の時間軸を
少しでも繋げることができればと思っています
そして 今ご紹介しているのは
ある方のお宅の茶の間に貼られていた紙です
ここに書かれている数字は事故から６ヶ月後
つまり2011年の3月の６ヶ月後から
避難した飯館村の方が自宅に戻る度に
そのおうちの中 そして
周囲で測った放射線量をメモした物です
カレンダーの裏にメモ書きをして
茶の間に貼り付ける
だれでもする行為ですよね
その何気ない暮らしの中に
放射線量という何気なくないものが
同居してしまっているのが
飯館村の今の状況です
それは福島県のほかの地域でも
あることでしょう
それが暮らしの一部であり
ある意味では
その土地の時間軸の一つの所に
刻まれてしまったという現実も
私たちは受け止めねばなりません
皆様はこの時間軸に刻まれた一つの事象を
どんな風に受け止められますか
私たちは こうして
博物館だからできることを行うと一緒に
「会津・漆の芸術祭」の時に行ったように
アーティストの力を借り
そしてアートの力を借りて
福島のことを記録することも行っています
「はま・なか・あいづ
文化連携プロジェクト」という
福島県の各団体 NPOさんや大学さんや
文化施設と一緒に行っている事業では
いくつかのプロジェクトを行っているのですが
岡部昌生さんという
フロッタージュをする作家さんには
2012年から参加をしていただいています
これは岡部さんが飯館村で
石碑のフロッタージュを採っているところです
人が住むことができなくなり
もしかしたら もうしばらくはその時間軸を
誰かが 繋げなくては
ならなくなったような土地で
その土地の歴史を少しでも残すことが
できればという思いもあって
石碑のフロッタージュを行っていきました
そして 津波被災地の歴史も刻んでいます
この画像は 南相馬市で行っていた
フロッタージュの制作の様子です
津波によって大きな物が
たくさん流されていきました
もちろん 建物も
今 ご覧いただいているのは
南相馬市の沿岸部の住宅が
流され残された基礎です
この基礎の上に
大きな物がたくさん流された後に
付いた傷痕が残っていました
フロッタージュという技法は
そのかすかな気配を
このように紙に刻み込むことができます
白く浮かび上がっている所は
へこんでいる所
黒く描かれている所は
上にコンクリートが残っている所です
つまり 白くなっている所は
傷が付けられた痕なんですね
コンクリートに傷が付くほど
重たい あるいは固い物が
すごい勢いで流されて来なくては
こんな傷痕は付きません
岡部さんは この土地の時間軸の一つと
なってしまったこの津波の記録をも
こうして私たちと一緒に
記録してくれています
そして ここ数年間の活動として
行われているのが
除染によって新たに生まれてしまった
福島の状況の記録です
これは飯館村のある神社なのですが
除染のため 大きなご神木を
切らねばならなくなりました
長い年月 氏子の皆さんや
神社を見守ってきた
大事な大事なご神木です
氏子の皆さん 宮司さんたちは
悩んで悩んで悩んだ結果
仕方がないということで
切ることに決めたそうです
今見ていただいても
とても大きな木だということが
分かると思います
岡部さんはこの切り株を
フロッタージュの技法でこすり取ることで
この木の年輪から その木の大きさ
そして ここで飯舘の人たちを
見守ってきた年月の長さを伝えてくれました
そして同時に とても無残に残っている
チェーンソウの傷痕は
私たちが それを切り倒すという選択を
この土地の人たちに強いてしまった
という事実をも伝えています
このこともまた
この飯舘の時間軸の中に刻まれた一つです
こうして生まれた作品たちは
展示という手法で伝えることができています
伝えるという博物館の役割は
こうして展示することの中で
果たせているのかなとも思っています
私たちはこうして博物館だから出来ること
そして伝えることを試みてきました
そして 今私たちがこうして行ってきた活動の
ほんのわずかなことですが
皆さんにお伝えして そして考えて欲しいな
と思っているのは
皆さんお一人お一人にも
時間軸があるということです
今 ここにいらっしゃる皆さんが
生を受けた瞬間のその先祖に連なる時間軸は
もちろんですけれども
ここの末廣酒造さんで こうして場を
ご一緒させていただいている時間を
共有できているのも
末廣さんの
ここに酒造りを始められて 繋いできた
この数百年の歴史の積み重ねがあって
私たちはここに今立てています
そのように 皆さんのそれぞれが
お持ちの時間軸は
多くのいろいろな時間軸の組み合わせで
織物を織りなすようにして 成り立っています
是非 皆さんの時間軸一つ一つを
振り返ってみて下さい
私たち博物館は
きっと皆さんがその時間軸を振り返るときに
お役に立つのではないかなと思っています
そして 時間軸を振り返るということは
皆さんが携わっているいろんな物事や
それから その土地 訪れた土地 働く土地
いろんな土地への思いを
また変えてくれる力があるのでは
ないかなとも思っています
さらにもう一つ言わせていただくと
いろんな時間軸の先端の集合体が
今になっています
この同じ現代を生きる私たちの
一つ一つの時間軸は
こうやって時間を共有することで
交わることもありますが
多く 知らないまま
それぞれが時間軸を積み重ねることもあります
しかし 違う離れた所に あるいは
隣の声をかけない誰かの持っている時間軸を
知ること あるいは見つけることで
何か別の発見があることもあると思います
それが別の社会
あるいは別の考え方や生き方を
知ることに繋がるのではないでしょうか
そんな時 きっと
アーティストやアートの目線は
皆さんの心の中にある
何かのスイッチを探しあてて
スイッチが入る時の
お手伝いをしてくれると思っています
是非 博物館とそしてアートを信じて
皆さんの時間軸と心の中のスイッチを
探してみて下さい
そうすることで 私は社会がちょっとずつ
変わっていくのではないかなと思っています
以上です
（拍手）